ladies and gentlemen there's a weird
myth that people on wall street these
investment gurus are somehow smart
they're not
not only can monkeys beat the average
wall street genius mastermind but
they're not actually that hard to fool
history is full of investors getting one
over on wall street selling them
terrible companies that they later have
to take on after they invest in it it's
a practice as old as time that's even
how kevin o'leary the great shark on
shark tank made his money in the first
place was uh selling a garbage company
at the height of the dotcom bubble and
today we're covering one of those
stories of what happens when you try to
impersonate youtube and tell everyone
that you got the pop and new show that
all the millennials love well let's go
to the board and check it out ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the 10 million
studio i'm your host coffee zilla and
today we're talking about a company
you've probably never heard of before
aussie media guys it's the new hotness
with millennials all the jinzy the gen y
the gen x we're all loving it and
goldman sachs actually wanted to buy it
for 40
million dollars let's take a a little
peep at their poppin youtube channel
that must be worth a lot of money
because goldman sachs is not coming to
zilla by the way pump the stock uh
they're not coming to zillow with 40
million dollars let me tell you that
right now and uh i want to find out what
the competition's like what the geniuses
on goldman sachs big brains think the
pop and youtube channels look like oh
3 000 subscribers from ozzy media and oh
2 000 views guys that's what it looks
like when you're just really in the
zeitgeist when you're really
when you're really touching the pulse of
common media this is what goldman sachs
is looking for guys give me a call over
sex if you want actually somebody you
know let me know i'll sell out i don't
care i'll sell out but anyway let's get
into this article it's hilarious this is
a this is just a classic case of trying
to sell sh and make it look like gold
and goldman sachs almost believing it
because they're not too bright that's
the amazing thing this is what how you
know there's so much money in banking is
people at goldman sachs are really still
kicking after they almost got fooled by
stuff like this and they're making tons
of money let me don't get me wrong all
right ozzy media was started by this guy
carlos watson who apparently worked as a
cable news anchor he's basically saying
i got this poppin youtube channel and he
says you know where many of its videos
attracted more than a million views guys
they're a million view channel and
apparently goldman sachs found this
credible somehow and they decided to set
up a meeting who with well alex piper of
course the head of unscripted
programming for youtube originals
goldman sachs wanted to ask the experts
are they really the great thing that we
think they are apparently it was
supposed to be a zoom call but for some
reason alex piper was late and they said
hey this guy the got head of youtube
originals can't figure out um how zoom
works so let's do a conference call
instead now this is where things took a
a twist and the geniuses at due
diligence for goldman sachs actually
started to realize maybe um they were
being duped here oh this is such a great
story as alex piper spoke the man's
voice began to sound strange to goldman
sachs team as though it had been
digitally altered the four people said i
wonder and it was at this point that i
wondered how obvious it would have to be
for these guys to realize you know this
was altered like was it just like one of
those like alexa voices from amazon like
yes they are actually making quite a bit
of money at goldman sa
not cold and sex over at youtube.com we
love them at youtube.com they get a lot
of ad revenue so anyways these guys at
goldman sachs decide hey this is too
weird even for us so they reach out to
mr piper and he basically tells him i've
never talked to you guys in my life that
was somebody impersonating me
and of course there's only one person
who'd be interested in impersonating
them for aussie media
ozzy media obviously the big sleuths
i guess over at um google decided to get
to the bottom of this and they found out
that it was actually this guy samir rao
the co-founder and chief operating
officer of ozzie who could have thought
of that
i wonder what they said like hey that
was you on the phone right uh no it's
like the same voice and here's and
here's my favorite part okay guess guess
what he says is the reason that he
impersonated and lied to goldman sachs
in order to fake millions of views in
order to pretend and get them to buy him
out for 40 million dollars can you guess
the reason let me give you two options
was it because samir rao wanted um 40
million dollars by hook or crook or b
was it mental health
[Music]
if you guessed mental health crisis
you'd be right
oh no i'm having such a mental health
crisis i have to fake millions of views
for a 40 million dollar investment guys
i don't know what came over me i was
feeling a little depressed it's it's my
mental health
guys by the way this isn't to make light
of mental health this is to make light
of this con man this is what you call it
you call it being a con man you don't
call it mental health crisis you call it
i i was a con man i wanted to teach you
guys yo this guy's standing behind the
bodies of so many people with actual
mental health issues and he's saying uh
i had to cheat you out of 40 million
dollars so that's why i'm giving him a
hard time on that guys i just want to be
clear about that but um mr watson i
guess he's associated with ozzy says
samir is a valued colleague and a close
friend i'm proud that we stood by him
while he struggled does that mean you
didn't fire him and don't pretend like
nobody and ozzy knew like are they
trying to pretend they didn't know wait
a second i just realized mr watson he's
actually the leader of aussie you're
telling me the guy mr watson who's in
talks with goldman sachs to go ahead and
get this investment you're saying he
didn't know that samir rao was faking
this i'm gonna go ahead and call
[ __ ] on that dude
you're just as bad i bet mr watson put
it up to it i don't know if that's true
i'm just it's wild speculation probably
not true i shouldn't say that i'm not
gonna say that uh but what i will say is
carlos watson he definitely knew how
could how could you not know that it's
your buddy on the other line like let's
say miss like carlos is on one line
right and he's like talking to goldman
sachs he's like hey alex piper chime in
and you hear that you're you're like uh
vp or whatever you hear him on the other
line be like yeah we're great we're
thriving oh i i honestly i know that uh
probably no one's gonna go to the jail
for this but i say just my opinion
just my opinion that's what i say i say
all of them just just do a little just
just to get a little that i mean
honestly it's not that dissimilar from
what uh elizabeth holmes did so why
would this guy why should this guy get
any uh nicer of a treatment i mean i say
look dude i say give him what's coming
because it can't be legal to uh
impersonate someone from like another
executive team can it like it's
unbelievable to me the way this article
talks it talks like oh yeah maybe
something happens maybe it doesn't like
we don't really know it's private
business that's what private business
deals like that's what they do right
this sounds weird even for me and look
if it sounds like i'm being a harsh on
goldman sachs here it's because i looked
into this youtube channel i did my own
two minutes of due diligence here and um
i could have called this a fraud from a
mile away i mean it's so funny this new
york times article spends like half of
its time basically saying well it seems
irregular that you know they're they
don't really seem to be doing as well
publicly as pr as they're privately
saying but all you really have to do is
just go to their youtube channel one
time it doesn't take a big data genius
to figure out what's going on here
37 views 45 views 16 views 26 views and
then on the videos with views right this
one with 91 000 views supposedly you go
to it
and they only have 475 likes and zero
comments i mean that is unheard of i
don't know if goldman sachs needs to
hire me as a due diligence expert over
there for youtube but you don't get 91
000 views and zero comments without
having to artificially inflate those
numbers right whether it be through paid
advertising or botting views or some
shenanigans basically i've never seen a
youtube channel with that bad of
engagement unless there's something fake
here so i mean i'm gonna go ahead and
guess that if you had just left this
video without like trying to
artificially pump it up to be something
it's not you're probably going to see
viewership like we saw with the their
other videos like 10 views 50 views this
is a dead youtube channel that they're
trying to sell as being worth 40 million
dollars
again it happens all the time in silicon
valley but it's just incredible to me
that i'm not getting that 40 million
dollars ladies and gentlemen i mean come
on over here we've actually got the
stock is pumping over here what are we
getting for it nothing and take a listen
to some of this uh inspirational genius
millennial programming here
[Music]
if you're alive you eat
that may be the most profound thing i've
ever heard if you're alive you eat if
you're alive you also might breathe
guys this is the kind of podcasting you
can expect from this channel like holy
crap this was so obvious that these guys
were fake and it's funny to me that um
the only reason they seem to seem to
have been found out was this fake call
right like if they hadn't done the fake
call this is why i'm like giving goldman
sachs such a hard time about this is
that it's so obvious that they were not
what they said they were but it took
like this completely ridiculous
preposterous situation of like faking a
call with youtube in order to get found
out when it should have been like two
seconds of oh yeah these guys are
basically full of it like it like takes
like one second and so the fact that
they almost basically got 40 million
dollars and got out and this guy
basically cashed out i guess i mean i
don't know it's just absolutely
incredible to me and such a like sign of
sign of the fact that really hey guys
sometimes the experts are not who you
think they are right you think they've
got it all figured out and actually um
monkeys outperform them in the stock
market or you find out that mattel buys
out a your learning company in what
people then call the worst deals of all
time and you make this guy seem like
some savvy businessman when in actuality
he sold you just a bill of goods but
anyways that's basically it guys i hope
you enjoyed
and um i guess yeah my big takeaway is i
am for sale for 40 million dollars too
actually let me say that if we all get
bought out by an investment bank we're
all hey we're all going to the top
that's all i'm going to say you're all
in shareholders dude we're cashing out
that's i think what i'm realizing is we
should have been faking numbers and
courting these deals all along jpmorgan
call me dude thanks for watching big
investigations coming
what a up you're a fraud are you the
same no you're not